I've eaten dessert virtually every night
for 20 years and I've been able to
maintain a six-pack for that entire
period of time is you have to figure out
what your goal is either trying to get
bigger you're trying to get smaller from
there you start at number seven all the
way up to 21. you go from Extreme Weight
Loss to moderate weight loss to
maintenance to moderate weight gain to
extreme weight gain so let's say I'm a
200 pound guy and I want to get leaner
so I'm going to go to moderate cut and
I'm going to say 10 and so I'm going to
multiply 200 which is my weight times 10
which is this coefficient which gives me
2 000 calories here's step three you
multiply your weight 200 pounds again
you multiply it by one means 200 grams
of protein every pound of lean meat is
100 grams of protein so if you need 200
grams you need two pounds we have 2 000
calories and we know we have to eat 200
grams of protein all you have to do is
figure out where you want to get your
200 grams of protein from and figure out
how many calories are in that thing so I
subtract my 200 grams of protein and the
calories associated with those meals
from my 2000 in this example and I would
have 880 calories left over those 880
calories you can do whatever you want
with them